THE RULES COMMITTEE FOR MONDAY
APRIL TWENTY THIRD IS HEREBY
CALLED ORDER. PLEASE BE ADVISED
THAT AUDIO AND VIDEO RECORDING
COMPANIES PROCEED IS BEING MADE
RESULTS BEING TELEVISED. AUGMENT
SECTOR PIECE CULPABLE COOLEY
HERE CUNNINGHAM CARILLO IF THERE
BROUGH HERE. FRIEDMAN GALLAGHER
GRAYSON HERE MAYES HERE NAZARIAN
PRESENT SOLACE DOESN'T WALDRON.
WE HAVE A QUORUM AND WE HAVE
CONSENT AGENDA. IS OUR MOTION ON
THE CONSENT AGENDA UBER MISS
CARILLO SECONDED BY MS
CERVANTES.
I'M MANAGE SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL COOLEY. AYE COOLEY AYE
CUNNINGHAM CARILLO. CARILLO I'VE
CERVANTES. SURVIVE SAYS I'VE
FRIEDMAN GALLAGHER GRAYSON. AYE
GRAYSON AYE MAIENSCHEIN MAYES
AYE NAZARIAN.
JERRY AND I SOLIS. SOLACE AYE
WALDRON AYE WALDRON AYE.
VERY GOOD THAT MOTIONS YOU PASS
AND LESS RULES FOR HIS INJURED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH